[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Black Widow video we just
got some new footage of them filming a
very special scene so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs the reason why everyone's talking
about Thunderbolts is because it's a
very thunderbolt specific character that
was spotted on set and they've already
finished filming principal photography
so everyone's thinking that they're
filming their post-credits scene right
now so we'll explain the footage there
are a whole bunch of Easter eggs if
you're brand new to my channel I do
Marvel videos every week so be sure to
subscribe to get the videos there's also
a new giveaway stuff I'll explain at the
end of the video to very general spoiler
warning for the Black Widow movie you
know pretty much everything about her
between all the flashbacks in the
previous movies and what they've told us
so far so I don't really consider it
spoilery and some of this is a little
bit of speculation based on some very
concrete things that we've seen on set
but this past week they were filming a
scene for the Black Widow movie with a
much older looking version of general
Thunderbolt Ross he's using a walking
stick to assist himself looks way older
than William Hurt in real life way older
than when he appeared during Captain
America Civil War like they aged him up
a couple of years they did the exact
same thing for Robert Downey jr. iron
man after the five-year time jump in
Avengers end game they digitally aged
him up just a little bit to make it look
like five years ago by the reason why
this might be for the Black Widow
post-credit scene is because like I said
they've already finished filming pretty
much all the movie they've had their
wrap party for the cast and crew and
sent most of those people home so almost
all the people involved with actually
filming The Black Widow movie are done
the movie is getting ready to go off to
be edited and they're adding all the
visual effects typically they wait to
the very end of production like this the
last possible minute to film post-credit
scenes and usually for special actors
like Nick Fury in that first Ironman
post-credit scene they're only on set
for a single day or so and it usually
doesn't take that long because
post-credit scenes are typically just a
couple of characters in a room talking
to each other then they add some special
effects in the background later the
reason why everyone's thinking that this
might be setting up a Thunderbolts movie
or a Thunderbolts Disney Plus series is
because it looks like it's happening in
present day after avengers endgame in
the year 2023 in Thunderbolt Ross did
not need a cane during Captain America
Civil War he just had a heart attack see
how much younger he looks here in Civil
War than he does on set
the Black Widow movie in full makeup
usually they use makeup to make people
look younger but here it looks like
they're trying to make him look even
older why would you need a scene in
present-day with Thunderbolt Ross well
right now they've confirmed that the
Black Widow movie has set almost all in
the past between Captain America Civil
War and the beginning of Avengers
infinity war she still has the red hair
she hasn't died at yellow yet she's on
her break from Captain America's Secret
Avengers then there will be flashbacks
to when she was much younger in training
in the Red Room program to explain how
she came up through that there were some
deleted scene flashbacks to the Red Room
during Avengers age of Ultron
I'll play those in a second but the
Black Widow movie is meant to fill in
all that untold backstory that you've
only got whispers of in other movies
this is going braixen I'll need a
bankable once you're made of Marvel
we'll celebrate after the graduation
ceremony what if I fail
there's a very important reason why they
waited this long to do the Black Widow
movie yes we do all agree that they
probably should have done it before
avengers endgame so that our death made
a little bit more sense there's a whole
story about a behind-the-scenes civil
war between Kevin Feige
in the Marvel CEO about why they're
waiting this long to do the Black Widow
movie and it was mostly Kevin Feige
being stopped from making Black Panther
in the Black Widow movie the only reason
they made black panther is because the
Disney CEO called the Marvel CEO Ike
Perlmutter and said stop stopping them
from making these movies let them make
them if they want to so there was a big
question about why they waited this long
to do Black Widow and why it's said
during the past and why they didn't do
it before avengers endgame
that's why but in present day the
natascha black widow is still dead in
2023 the Russos as misleading as they
have been the past couple of years are
not lying when they say that she's dead
pretty much everybody associated with
Scarlett Johansson has talked about how
she died she sacrificed herself to help
save the Avengers if they're not gonna
roll back that sacrifice and bring her
back in present day recently Robert
Downey jr. talked about their reason for
transitioning away from the Marvel films
he Chris Evans Scarlett Johansson they
just felt like it was their time to go
the only reason that Scarlett Johansson
is coming back to do her movie is
because they never gave her a solo movie
so their logic that they're bending over
backwards to make this work is that it's
set during the past not in present day
but early theory is that the Black Widow
movie plot is heard trying to save her
sister Jelena Bulova from the taskmaster
that also gives them flashbacks to
Budapest they're in Budapest in the
relative recent present-day of Captain
America Civil War so there's all the
Budapest explainers that you ever wanted
in a black widow movie thematically the
importance of Budapest is that it was
the beginning of the Natasha Black
Widows redemption after Hawkeye offered
her spot on shield when he probably was
sent there to kill her so the theory
goes on to say that in the past before
infinity war picks up Black Widow is
successful in saving Jelena Belova but
then Jelena Bulova gets thrown in prison
to rot for a hot minute because of all
the red on her ledger and the terrible
stuff that she's done but then early
Black Widow post-credit scene Theory you
jump forward to present-day she's been
in prison this whole time through the
snap and then everyone getting blip back
Thunderbolt Ross comes to visit her in
3in offers Jelena biloba a very similar
type of deal that Hawkeye offered
Natasha Black Widows so many years ago
here's a chance to clear your name and
eventually earn your freedom Suicide
Squad style by recruiting her to a
Thunderbolts initiative a very dark
twist on the Nick Fury Ironman
post-credit scene I'm here to talk to
you about the Avengers initiative then
they just keep on seating that along
with Thunderbolt Ross recruiting other
people through Marvel phase 4 into phase
5 and whenever they want to eventually
do their Thunderbolts movie or a
Thunderbolts Disney Plus series you
asked now who else would be on that
Thunderbolts team because we have plenty
of villains that are still around alive
or rotting in prison that they could put
on that team there's about eight that we
know of right now they're obviously
going to introduce new villains during
Marvel phase four we can also include
them if they don't get killed off during
their movies so first there's Jelena
Bulova Black Widow of course the future
of that character in the MCU being that
she becomes the new Black Widow even
though technically everyone that
graduates from the Red Room are called
black widows next big character is the
taskmaster introducing him for the first
time during the Black Widow movie he's a
slam-dunk
Thunderbolts character hopefully they
don't kill him off Baron Zemo also
slam-dunk as the new Thunderbolts team
leader appearing next as the villain for
the Falcon and Winter Soldier Series
next year he led the Thunderbolts in the
comics just seems like a pretty easy
pick to put him on the team after he
gets done with Falcon and Winter Soldier
there's the ghost from the ant-man of
the wasp movie she's still on the run
right now they're still Justin Hammer
who's still rotting in Seagate prison
Sam Rockwell even said that he wants to
come back at some point he's good
comedic relief for that team
never see me coming look at this guy
what is so special about him I mean I
had an army of robots what's he done
he's got some dumb accent
his name's Trevor and what is that Sam
Rockwell's such a great actor I'm sure
they'll find someplace for him in the
MCU pretty soon but he should go without
saying Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk pretty
easy to do motion capture on William
Hurt no matter how much older he gets
it's relatively easy for them to do it
with Mark Ruffalo's Hulk character now
too they also still have the abomination
and the leader from The Incredible Hulk
movie who are still rotting in prison
right now you could always bring them
back and right now the rumor reported by
some of the Hollywood trades is that
they're spending 25 million dollars per
episode of each of these Disney Plus
series that works out to about a hundred
and fifty million dollars for six
episodes of television so it's kind of
like a six hour movie instead of getting
a two hour movie for those of you that
thought that Avengers endgame should
have been longer than three hours I've
seen a lot of you guys theories about
what's going on with taskmaster during
the Black Widow movie because he's
supposed to be one of the main villains
obviously there's a whole lot of stuff
going on because you have red guardian
who's sort of the Russian version of
Captain America David Harbor from
stranger things actually just finished
filming all of his red guardian scenes
he will be wielding the shield in the
red Guardian outfit during the movie all
of ray Guardians gear is meant to be the
Russian version of Captain America's
gear so he has a round shield just like
Captain America's with a big star on it
right now they've said that the Black
Widow trailer is gonna drop around the
same time that the Avengers endgame in
Avengers infinity war trailers dropped
in the past two years which is typically
at the end of November beginning of
December we'll also be getting a Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer in December -
there'll be a bunch of stuff happening
in December because we have Rick and
Morty season four this starting at the
end of November that'll spill through
the holidays
we have the new Mandalorian series which
is going to be airing episodes through
the holidays and The Witcher Netflix
series so I'll be doing videos for all
that stuff but leave your requests in
the comments below and there is a new
round of that spider-man far from home
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber and leave your
best Thunderbolts MCU theory on the
video
everybody click here for my Iron Man
video about how they're using him in
this special deleted scene to sit up
mutants in Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase 5
and click here for my non-spoiler
Joker movie review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]